is a big step toward making vaccines
safe for children this morning moderna
says it has already given the first
doses of its vaccine
to kids from six months of age to 12
years old
the two-part study is designed to show
how the children tolerate the vaccine
and to make sure it is safe and
effective for them our lead national
correspondent david begno spoke to one
family that's involved in a clinical
vaccine trial
david good morning to you good morning
so modernist expanding its age bracket
they had been doing age
12 to 17 but now they're doing even the
babies listen the principal investigator
of the modern trial here in houston
said they had more people signed up here
in houston and apparently they've got
the
biggest of the moderna trials so we said
well let's go to houston and we met two
sisters
whose mom and dad signed them up
it was blair davis's 15th birthday and
to celebrate she and her younger sister
dylan got into the car
headed to a clinic happy birthday wait a
minute
and they got a covet swab that's because
the davis sisters are part of moderna's
adolescent vaccine trials
and yesterday they got their second
shots no way to know if it's a placebo
or if it's the real thing but what do
you think
i think i got the placebo we're like
we're pushing for a fever we're pushing
for bodies
yes exactly because as doctors you know
that if that happens the body is
reacting
right something that's right they're
getting a response yeah we're looking
for a response
garvin davis and mindy jeter both
doctors are the girls parents
they say they applied to at least three
different adolescent trials
to get them protected was really
important for us so you felt like
getting them protected as early as
possible
would in the end protect you would
protect us it would protect their
grandparents and anyone else
for the next few days the girls will
have to record their temperatures and
any other symptoms in a digital journal
and in a few weeks they'll come back for
another checkup but for this family it's
not just about protecting themselves
from coving
i wanted them to be an example to set an
example to say hey
this vaccine is safe we actually as
doctors
trust our children getting this shot i
would say
unquestionably being african-american
really
played a role in really wanting our
girls to participate
it still is personal because as
african-american
physicians we understand the science of
it so we know what happened tuskegee we
know
what they were doing and how it was
wrong but this is not that like these
studies that are being done now
are being done in a way that i think we
should be able to trust them
if our kids can help get this trial
approved for other teenagers
i think it'll make everyone feel better
and be in a safer place
and getting kids vaccinated will be
critical to ending the pandemic
says cbs news medical contributor dr
david agus so we have to do everything
we can to get toward her immunity
and given that 25 percent of the united
states is
under the age of 21 this is going to
have to include children
dr aegis says adult vaccine trials
required
tens of thousands of participants in
order to prove that the vaccines
stopped people from getting sick and now
that we know the vaccines work
children's trials only need to answer
the important questions is it safe
period
and do they mount effective immune
responses period
and those are very easy to do with
smaller numbers of children
a few thousand children actually
starting with kids like dylan
and blair who spent her special day in a
houston clinic but
it's sort of sort of my duty like
as a houstonian to help out other
stadiums and this is one way i can do
that
how about that from a 15 year old civic
duty look dr anthony fauci says the
older kids could get vaccinated by the
fall
the younger kids by early next year
anthony yeah
underline that number david 25 of the
u.s under 21. that's an amazing stat
david thank you